The weak law of large
numbers tells us
that the sample mean--
that is, the average of
independent identically
distributed random
variables, Xi--
converges, in a certain sense,
to a number, namely the
expected value of the random
variables, Xi.
But it does not tell us much
about the details of the
distribution of the
sample mean.
The central limit theorem
provides us exactly with this
kind of detail.
It tells us that the sum of many
independent identically
distributed random variables
has approximately a normal
distribution.
The mean and variance of this
normal is easy to find if we
know the mean and variance of
the original random variables.
This enables us to carry out
approximate calculations
rather quickly by using
the normal tables.
We will start with a precise
statement of the central limit
theorem, and we will emphasize
that it is a universal result.
It holds no matter what the
distribution of the original
random variables, and for this
reason, it is very useful.
We will work through several
examples of the typical ways
that the central limit
theorem is used.
We will develop a refinement
that can be used when we are
dealing with discrete
distributions, which provides
us with even more accurate
approximations.
And finally we will revisit
the polling problem, and
inquire again about the number
of samples that are needed to
obtain a certain accuracy with
a certain confidence.
We will see that the central
limit theorem is much more
informative, much less
conservative, compared to the
conclusions that we had gotten
before based on the Chebyshev
inequality.